je crois que vous devriez traiter les
gens comme vous voulez être traité
n'avez-vous pas dit que tout
prend toujours une faveur par rapport à l'argent je pense que
Jésus a dit cela aussi mais je ne sais pas
vous pensez que tout le monde est un peu plus tôt
tout le monde pensait déjà que Tomas
allait rester au bureau je suis dehors sur
le terrain j'ai des gens qui travaillent pour moi mes
idées j'apprends le spectacle je suis le
quarterback et je ne vais pas seller
ce n'est pas à moi de le dire  n'était pas
forcément en forme et il avait
ce peigne plutôt élaboré
il avait cette confiance qui m'a attiré vers
lui mon père il m'a appris à croire
que tout le monde est bon et à être bon
avec tout le monde la vie est ridicule et toi
sache que je ne dirais jamais rien de mal à
propos de ton père devant toi mais
ton père est un fils de [ __ ]
malade qui devient un fils de [ __ ] malade ne
répète pas ça mais oui
ils jouent un rôle salut tu peux tu l'
as déjà fait  devez trouver un moyen de
survivre et vous saviez que vos choix étaient
mauvais mais  t vous avez dû survivre à Ricky si
réussi pendant si longtemps parce que nous l'avons
gardé juste assez petit pour réussir
comment se fait-il que vous vous retrouviez dans cette pièce avec moi en
ce moment en prenant des commandes de moi
c'est l'agent DiMaso plaçant soixante-
quinze mille dollars de cette mallette
pour  le maire carmine polito
va faire un tour
nous devons surmonter tous ces gars
c'est ce à quoi nous devons penser en
ce moment nous devons surmonter tous
ces gars elle doit être la meilleure que nous ayons
jamais faite